[Musique]
jeridi juridique des boîtes vides
juridiques boîte à outils même si ce
taux diminue mais elle semblait bien we
made it dans sas en gaz 1 2 3 4 des
watchmen juridique chez les victimes des
mêmes séries digérer geek du web if des
mois et des mois tant sinon si mais non
merci mais non merci ça use beaucoup
votre guitare habitat aura pour la
chansonnette sa part fait mais pour le
récital
alors pour le récital vous brancher
directement sur un gazomètre jaune avec
un masque t'oblige à dire n importe quoi
je veux te serre et autres de mes bras
je monte au ciel comme un vélo rouge au
départ que benson au bout c'est dans la
nature elle a battu brandon segal qu'un
vin soudain le bisou bisou bisou bisou
bisou bisou messieurs prend bien je suis
en transe vous êtes entre en russie en
transe à que la transbaie le one two
three des heat a d'abord
quand même dix mois on soit 12 jours un
nom joyeux anniversaire et un petit
beurre c'est pour you happy birthday to
you par un petit beurre c'est pour quand
on ne connaît pas une langue on sait
reprendre à sienne pour parler celle des
autres nouvelles ça vous me verrez par
lettre recommandée tropicale irène
abords de la halle à quel rythme j'ai
glissé au goitschel je veux te serrer au
creux de mes bras je monte au ciel comme
un ballon rouge
[Musique]
ces voitures est vraiment tu prends soin
minceur ou bisous bisous bisous ne l'a
pas remettre ça avec vous ou bisous
bisous ballon je fais mon seul autre
tombeau nation one 2 6 4
[Musique]
vous aimez c'est à dire qu'un passage
qui m'a échappé
voulant jouer oil 2 6 4 et encore gens
sautent hors c'est insolite
sachant que c'était un solo et un seul
ou insolites arrive d'ailleurs le titre
insolite solo avant mais c'est le style
rock weir qu'empire avec de grands
tiroirs le dessus en marre des titres
colonnes de chaque côté saveurs riches
avec l'empereur et la musique est
entièrement de vouvant entièrement non
non je dois l'avouer j'ai emprunté à
massenet en briguant dans werther oui le
barça joue werther dia charlotte ich
liebe dich abers flou butane
ce qui veut dire je t'aime mais ça sent
le gaz un sérum anti sano qui coûte 1 ya
eye-fi drive
m'en fous complètement debout
[Musique]